جاء هذا القرار الاممي بعد خمس سنوات من
تقديم فلسطين طلبها وذلك رغم ما تعرضت له
قيادتها من ضغوط وتهديدات مبطنه اسرائيليه
وامريكيه وبريطانيه لا غرابه في ان تسارع
اسرائيل على لسان مندوبها لدى الامم
المتحده الحالي والسابق الى مهاجمه القرار
ووصفه بانه وصمه عار للامم المتحده واتهام
الرئيس الفلسطيني بممارسه ارهاب دبلوماسيه
والمطالبه بمحاسبته والانتقام منه
والاعلان انه لا يحق لاي مؤسسه دوليه ان
تتهم اسرائيل بانها قوه احتلال في ارضها
الفلسطينيون بعد ان عيله صبرهم يعودون على
هذا القرار في ان يرد على المجتمع الدولي
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ويتصدى لما تنظر به
حكومه اليمين المتطرف الجديده من مخاطر
اليوم ان كنتم تؤمنون بالقانون الدولي
والسلام فانكم ستؤيدون فتوى محكمه العدل
الدوليه عندما تصدر وستقيفون في وجه هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لان الحريه والعدل
والسلم يجب ان تسود
القرار تاريخي ايضا من وجهه النظر
الفلسطينيه بمعنى ان المحكمه سوف تبث
بوجود اسرائيل على هذه الارض ان كان شرعي
او غير شرعي قانوني غير قانوني وسوف ترتكز
على كل مخرجات قواعد القانون الدولي منذ
75 عاما
عشر وقضايا اراد السؤال الفلسطيني البته
بشانها عدم قانونيه الاحتلال وان
الاستيطان والانتهاكات المستمره وطول
الاحتلال جرائم حرب والضم ممنوع وتغيير
الوضع القائم في مدينه القدس المحتله غير
قانوني وان منظومه قرارات شرعنتها اسرائيل
هي سياسه فصل عنصري وحق تقرير المصير
للشعب الفلسطيني غير قابل للتفاوض اسرائيل
الدوله التي اقيمت بقرار من الامم المتحده
اكثر الدول الاعضاء تمردا على قرارات هذه
المنظمه الامميه حماها في ذلك الفيديو
الامريكي والدعم الاوروبي لكن هذا التطور
يضع حماتها امام تحدي جدي بسبب طبيعه
حكومتها الجديده وليد العمري الجزيره رام
الله